hi my name is one I work for the
technology group in Wolfram research
today my talk is about to you
reinforcement learning system modeler
hello everyone my name is Wang I work
for the technology group in Wolfram
researched and today I would like to
talk about some experience when I study
reinforcement learning with system
modeler they start my for this talk I
show briefed shows a connection between
a control system and the reinforcement
learning and then use a system model to
create example and the using an existing
external implementation to optimize our
controller for this a system model model
so here we have a very basic diagram
which I in a brought from Wikipedia we
have an environment here which may be a
black box all could be also could be
something we already know the internal
mechanism but and we have an interpreter
which probes assistant and gets the
state and the reward after each step and
we also have an agent which given under
a certain policy will give the action to
the environment so just for the
reference the reward isn't need to be
positive it could be negative and the
goal here we want is to to find an
optimal policy that the agent can take
so after the end of each episode is the
reward could be maximized many research
very different perspective to you know
describes this loop in different ideas
many trains the Markov decision process
which is definitely correct but I would
like to show a pass from our feedback
control system to the reinforcement
learning so this is also a very basic
diagram for a feedback control system we
have a plant which can be defined within
OD'ing state space we also have an
output
action a controller that can take the
output and the generates the new input
for to the plant this is a very classic
feedback control system and I believe
you can find the similarity between
these two loops right so let's check the
details of the Markov decision process
how its defined we have the two small
sorry we have a set of the state we have
a set of ops actions we can take and we
have a discount register you can think
about the inflation rate we have
compared with the feedback control
system we have a two additional things
the probability P and the reward are
from state s to the next state s prime
under a certain action so for most a
control system we learned what I learned
and given a state and the input of the
next state is determined right but in
the Markov decision process there is a
possible probability distribution of
next state once even though the current
state and the input is given this making
the MDP
the Markov decision process you know a
superset of the feedback control system
and for the reward in the MDP we can
compared it to the object function in
linear and quadratic regulator but the
difference is we want to minimize the
object function loss for machining or QR
but we want to maximize the reward as a
accumulated reward in this process we
are going to use the system model to
represent the environment in
reinforcement learning so strictly
speaking the environment only contains a
plant but in most practice will combine
the plant and there's a audible function
as you know a combination of the
environment and the interpreter that
depends if you want to customize the
state and as a reward
you are going to get in terms of policy
the agent is going to the agency is
going to follow most a widely used
policy is bursting pose a greedy policy
that means when you standing one state
and the look and the next of possible
actions you will choose action and lead
to the states that may brings most
rewarding the feature so if we know the
probability table looks like we can give
each state of value and choose a strong
the state value function similarly we
can have a cue function which maps the
tuple of the state and action and twos
rewards it may bring the future with
such a cue function we even don't need
to know what the probability table is
which means we don't we can treat the
environment as in black box purely we
can choose you know we have two
functions we can choose different
function to learn and we can choose
different optimization message learn
whether it's Monte Carlo or it's
temporal difference or a combination of
both I have a recent poll example here
so the black jack' because the room may
differ from casino to casino I just
prefer the blackjack blackjack game
being a reinforcement learning book the
automatic oh is simple get larger the
other player you'll want to get the
larger school compared with the dealer
but do not exceed 21 points I implement
with Wolfram language the major function
contains a reset function which start a
new game we have an observed function
which checks the dealers card and
the card along the players hands we also
have action function which you know
taken action and whether is to draw a
new card or to check the current card to
see who is the winner we can use the
Monte Carlo policy to do we can use
Monte Carlo simulation
here to wrong the game like ten thousand
times and a draw either a cue function
or a V function there's a cue function
in every function in this game where
looks like a table so there is randomly
selected several samples from the Q
function Q value set and there's a V
value set so if you're familiar with
reinforcement the reinforcement learning
I suppose you heard a framework called
called the gin from Albany I this Python
based app framework mailings of the true
problems providers benchmark for
different reinforcement learning
algorithm and then standardized function
for each for different environment so
you know the research can use this for
publications but yes this framework
require you to you know wipe your
implementation into Python language but
I think with you know with the
reinforcement learning getting more and
more matured many people want to apply
this technical to some real questions
for sure you can rewrite your you know
implementation to in with Python but
that's not necessary
you can you can just use system model to
simulate the plant because a system
modeler is a powerful platform you can
you know create complicated model easily
so in WSM link
which connects the mathematical system
modular the real-time simulate function
can simulate a model with its time its
simulation time synchronized with the
real time and so our Creator invented
pendulum as an example here let's take a
look at let's take a look and the
invented pendulum as the model is very
simple we have a cot we have a pork neck
to do with a frictionless rotation angle
and a would force is applied to the cut
and as a force is the magnitude of the
force is defined as the input u we put
our Tuesday we put two sensors one two
probes cot positions the other is to
prop the angle of the poor between the
vertical lines so now let's check how
the model in system model is connected
in Mathematica so let's load it first
so here we you know defines delta T and
other parameters
similarily we have a reset function to
start each game the in issue
conditioning is randomly generated we
have a observe function which probes the
position of the cut and the angle of the
pole we have step function which takes
the water force as an input and simulate
the model falls at Del T ty we also have
check function C if the pole has already
fallen to the ground if it's already you
know fourth onto the ground we just
stops again this is this is display
function just Falls convolutional neural
network which we will talk a bit later
so we can implement a very simple
controller here like a proportional
feedback controller and it doesn't it
works not bad and to be honest with a
random controller you know we have three
options where's it going push
left-hander push all push writes with a
random controller it can simulate 420
steps and with this proportional
feedback controller it can simulate a
roughly by average 50 steps well this is
a little exceptional one but we we can
still use a Monte Carlo simulation to
accumulate a large number of samples for
as a cue function or V function Q value
or V value and feed it into a predict
functioning Mathematica or a new network
function you create by yourself
so let's look at that we define a
discount rate and define how the Q value
is generated and we can wrong 10-episode
once we accumulate all the data samples
we can just simply feed the data into
predict function but I mean of course
10-episode may be a little small but for
the time just just here now by default a
user random forest ax 2 generates
multiple a decision tree so a controller
can be used once you have the current
state and you put all the actions into
this predict function and tell which can
generate the largest Q value so you
choose that one all you can define new
network function by yourself this is
what it is not specific for this problem
but I can still use it we slightly you
know format of the training data and
also puts the training data into the new
network function it's gonna take a bit
of time so because in mass market to
11.2 we introduced a new functionality
called which allow Mathematica to
communicate with external
pison or GS notice session so I will ask
you how to if you have already have a
reinforcement algorithm and implements
somewhere else how to connect how to use
that existing training scheme for the
model in system modular we have
assumption here so the Q value for each
state tuple equals to the immediate
reward plus the discount rated x z--
maximize the Q value of all next
possible state after taking this action
so with this function if our options is
in a finance visiting are fine and
discrete space we
can index all the actions and create a
new net creator Universal function Maps
the state to to a vector of Q values so
each element in this vector represents
the Q value from the state after taking
the corresponding actions the loss
function is simple it's defined as the
distance between the left-hand side and
the right-hand side so for the left-hand
side we already know the state is and we
already know which action we are going
to take so we just put to the state into
the new network generator vector of Q
values and the choose accordingly based
on the index of action we are going to
take and for the right hand side we have
we know the immediate reward is we
already define the discount rate and we
just put it the next state into the new
network function and then we get a
vector for the Q value for the next
state and we apply an Maximizer operator
and extract to the max value from the
output Q value of vector so I implement
here but I don't think I have time to
show you
so with this function you can wrong the
simulation and for multiple times and
but each a set of multiple episode is
considered as one training force this X
for this new network controller so you
probably need to wrong even more to get
a better performance and with you can
check the how many steps you can take
from the beginning to the end and
sometimes it will get you know a maximum
an optimal controller but yeah it really
takes some lucky energy to try very many
times
[Music]
yep I think that's all my talk today any
questions
[Applause]